Funchal Airport, on the island of Madeira,
is one of the most difficult places
in Europe to land a commercial plane.
It wasn't easy to build a runway here
back in the 1960s.
Madeira is basically one huge mountain
just sticking out of the Atlantic Ocean.
There isn't any part of this island
flat enough for long enough
that it can support a runway.
But with a lot of earthmoving,
it was possible for them to build
one short runway, enough for the
relatively lightweight aircraft of the day.
And then European tourism and
the package holiday boom started,
and planes
kept getting bigger.
The runway was extended another 200 meters
in the '70s, but it still wasn't enough.
There was nowhere to extend to.
There was another bit of cliff,
a few hundred meters to the east,
that could technically be flattened.
But between there and the existing runway,
there was nothing but air.
The only option was to build a bridge:
big enough, wide enough and
strong enough, somehow,
to handle a fully loaded
airliner landing on it.
Basically:
to put most of the runway up on stilts.
So that's what they did.
IN PORTUGUESE:
It's only when you get
underneath the runway and stand up close
that you realise the sheer scale of this.
It's unlike any other space
I've ever been in.
There's a whole boatyard under here,
a go kart track.
The noise you can hear is industry.
There's more than 30 metres
between each of these pillars.
The tallest ones are more than
50 metres high.
Just the base of each pillar is taller
than I am.
The foundations go
far down into the ground.
This whole area had to be flattened
and stabilised
so it could stand up
to the weight.
On its own, a runway on stilts
shouldn't make a landing more difficult.
A runway is a runway, right?
The difficulty comes from
what's around and under it.
The mountains cause fast gusting winds.
And the approach has a late, low turn
that requires special training.
And pilots aren't even allowed to start
that training until they've had 200 hours
flying the type of aircraft
they'll be landing here.
In the airport documentation,
there's a line that says pilots should
watch the wind indicators on the runway
because occasionally, "they will indicate
wind from opposite directions".
To be clear, this is safe.
There hasn't been an incident
on this runway in nearly half a century.
For most passengers, this is just a normal
landing at a normal airport.
Or at worst,
a bit of a bumpy, turbulent landing.
And the reason for that is
a lot of pilot training
and some very big civil engineering.